donc je rentre le ventre et 20 des
caméras d'accords cadres et hauts alors
[Musique]
en tête des sondages ont surtout porté
sur les intentions de vote les personnes
ne sont pas allés voter avait exprimé
d'intention de vote très particulière et
ceux qui ne sont pas allés voter ne
ressemblait pas à ceux qui sont allés
voter du coup le score de différentes
formations notamment celui des listes du
rassemblement national qui a un
électorat beaucoup plus populaires ce
score là a été très largement surévalué
et probablement le principal échec des
sondages depuis leur création en france
les intérêts et sociologiquement très
différenciée
on sait qu'aujourd'hui seuls 48% des
français s'intéressent à la campagne
présidentielle une bonne partie de la
population ne se politise que lorsque
c'est véritablement le moment du choix
les candidats qui sont le plus écouté
parce qu'ils suivent en permanence
l'actualité ces candidats tels eric
zemmour sont favorisés par rapport à
d'autres qui eux ont une audience
beaucoup plus populaire et donc beaucoup
moins mobilisé hors des périodes
électorales
[Musique]
oui très probablement puisque ces
sondages sont de plus en plus facile à
produire par ailleurs la vie politique
demeure profondément instable à l'ancien
clivage gauche droite ne s'est pas
complètement substituer le nouveau
clivage entre les populistes les
progressistes et que donc partout on se
pose des questions non seulement l'issue
de la présidentielle n'est pas connu
mais en plus on ne connaît même pas
comment va se restructurer cette offre
ça justifie en tout cas aux yeux des
commanditaires de la réalisation de tous
ces sondages
[Musique]
oui forcément vous savez les sondages ne
joue jamais un tel rôle politique comme
au mans et dans le moins de
signification là vous avez un jeu une
espèce de fascination réciproque qui
veut dire entre l'opinion et les
sondages ça créé une forme d'animations
pré électorale sans aucune garantie de
pérennité pour les scores que l'on
constate actuellement
[Musique]